it's a weird one nothing out of place no
murder weapon and no motive there's just
a couple lying dead in their bed the
proof is always out there detectives you
just have to know where to find the
pudding excuse me sir you can't be here
the SUBSCRIBE scene it's okay he's the
greatest sex-crime investigator in
history if it isn't detective Chuck
Vaughn protective Sally Ferguson oh you
could use a genius right now Tom Samwell
whatever God Sam well well well
Tommy I've got ourselves a hard case
here all we've got is two bodies both
dead naked one man one woman in the bed
two scented candles by the nightstand
how did you no sign of forced entry he
loved the way they smelled he wanted to
cross the threshold the way they had on
their wedding day
dirty dog
you would have experienced that pleasure
right here anniversary a couple was
together for a while I wanted to spice
things up check the date on the
photograph Vaughn's right today was
their 15th wedding anniversary this is
huge
and what the was that you just pulled
your dick out and started jerking off at
the crime scene
Sam well he's the best there is by
putting himself in the perpetrators
mindset he's able to solve crimes that
involve sex bag this up some call it a
blessing it's more like a curse is that
what it feels like threesome if you
wanted to see them didn't you you wanted
to watch 25 feet from the bedroom across
from the kitchen
you didn't want to see their flesh yet
did you know he stood right here
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
roleplay gone wrong check the logs I've
got a bloody fire poker
we've got our murder weapon um why do
your revelations require masturbation
why do kittens require milk no not the
same thing hey hey he's the most
brilliant goddamn detective I know put
your ego aside and give Vaughn his space
my ego we've got captain pud-puller
flinging his fluids all over the crime
scene wait he knew them they were close
so close too close he he I think he knew
the house
why how what did you want you sick
bastard
he wanted to see what he saw everyday
only closer closer
he was close to home
[Laughter]
all right let's go get him go go gone
that was amazing
I'm sorry that I doubted you your
methods are unorthodox but I cannot
argue with your results
no hard feelings uh no no not gonna do
that
[Music]
you